[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the sony xperia z1 or z1 as a lot of
people will call it it's basically a
tuned up and refined xperia z
surprise all right so it is a major step
up on the inside from the xperia z
flagship and we'll get to that in a
second but on the outside it is more of
an incremental upgrade with some minor
tweaks here and there and improvements
to the design and the overall way it
feels on the hand so the whole actual
outside of the xperia z1 is reinforced
metal with this black plastic band on
the inside which is good because it's
not the other way around now the buttons
on the side of the phone i think are
really well placed especially for
smaller hands they're in the right spots
and with the typical sony full edge to
edge glass on the front and the back of
the phone it does have two effects one
it makes the phone feel super premium
and high end in the hand expensive even
it's actually heavier but number two it
makes the phone feel actually a little
bit more delicate the metal doesn't
quite wrap around to the front or the
back so if you drop this phone on either
of its faces it will hit glass so i kind
of got these mixed feelings holding in
the hand it doesn't feel bad by any
means but just like the nexus 4 and the
iphone it naturally made me more careful
not to drop it so a lot of people are
going to love the look of and just the
pure aesthetics of the xperia z1 and
that's great because it's a really good
looking phone but to me it still has the
same problem as the original xperia z
where it doesn't really know if it wants
to be a ruggedized device or not it's a
great looking device in the first place
but then you add the fact that it's ip58
certified so that means it's dust proof
it's water resistant for up to one meter
deep for up to 30 minutes so in order to
do that it has to add a whole bunch of
these different things where it needs to
cover up all the different ports it has
to have almost no openings the speaker
has to be significantly worse it has
this permanent screen protector on that
you cannot remove and a whole bunch of
other things that are all sealed up
about the phone
to make it ip58 certified but does
anyone really need that in a phone and
at the end of the day it's glass on the
front and the back and it's not exactly
the most rugged thing in the world
i feel like if this device was not ip58
certified and if they didn't cover every
single port with flaps and if they
didn't worry about the display being
certified and had an open speaker and
just had a a much more traditional built
device it would be a lot more appealing
to me but all this stuff is no different
than the xperia z and neither is the
power button that feels a little bit
mushy or the completely awful speaker on
the bottom all these are sacrifices that
sony's made to get this beautiful device
to survive some rain or some mud or
being dropped in the shallow end of a
pool or something like that the worst of
it is actually the sim card tray it's an
absolute disaster to get the sim card
into the flexible plastic tray thing and
then into the phone and taking it out is
even worse so thankfully most people
will only have to do that one time but
there are also some nice subtle things
that have changed on the good end like
the notification led inside the earpiece
is probably the prettiest on a phone
next to the lg optimus g and you'd
probably never know if no one told you
but there is a permanent screen
protector on the glass that you'd
probably never see if you weren't
looking for it and speaking of that
display it's a completely similar story
to the xperia z it's rocking a 5 inch
1920x1080 panel which brings it to 441
pixels per inch super sharp with bright
vibrant colors and relatively contrasty
pleasing images until you turn it off
axis that's where it falls apart because
of the protector that they put on the
display to help it pass that ip58
certification the xperia z1 has some
pretty poor viewing angles when it comes
to color reproduction you can see here
compared to the moto x that it starts
getting weird at only about 30 degrees
off axis and by then it just looks
totally washed out and you're missing
all the color and contrast
as you know the rest of the quirks about
this phone like the flaps that you have
to open to charge it and the glass front
and back and the new design they're all
things that you can get used to after
just a little bit of use but this
display this display was the one thing
that i could never get over because it's
the one thing that you have to look at
when you're using your phone and a lot
of people argue you'll never use the
display off axis but trying to show just
one other person uh some movie or
something on your phone you'll have to
deal with these incredibly poor viewing
angles even when gaming when you turn
the phone a lot you're gonna have to
deal with this but there's another
hardware feature that we can talk about
that's gotten a lot of attention on the
z1 and that is the camera and it's a
pretty good one now a lot of people
automatically look at that 20 megapixels
and assume whoa it must be in the top
five smartphone cameras now uh it's
actually not but don't get me wrong it's
not bad at all it's like number six but
it has its pros and cons but first i
want to say that this phone has just
about the perfect button layout for
taking pictures like a boss so anyway
opening up the camera app from any
shortcut first thing you'll notice is
the viewfinder frame rate is very high
and it takes you into sony's superior
auto mode by default which is supposed
to choose the best photo mode to use by
evaluating the situation but it turns
your image size down to 8 megapixels and
turns the image stabilization off by
default which is weird so i always get
in the habit of switching to manual mode
and turning it to 20 megapixels and
turning the software stabilization on
now the phone's camera actually has a
pretty big sensor bigger than the one in
the galaxy s4 and in the iphone so if
you want to take that for granted it
does give you a nice shallow depth of
field it also has a benefit of sony
optics and sony like we know makes great
cameras so that should be all good there
but the images
were decent at best they're not going to
shock anyone that you took them from a
camera phone or anything mostly because
the image processing is meh and the
colors really aren't that vibrant they
sometimes look a bit dull but the
sharpness is definitely there and the
focus was pretty accurate in regular
light so they tend to look alright the
camera really struggled though in low
light i have to mention that the very
colors and the artifacts and the noise
patterns in low light were just really
bad the flash didn't help either so
there's no real optical image
stabilization so it's really not that
good in low light but lucky for us sony
has put a lot of effort into the xperia
skin and the camera is one place where
you can really see a lot of it in action
the manual mode has that exposure
control dial so you can choose how to
meter the image manually which is nice
and again it's in that sweet spot with
the awesome button layout i really like
shooting with it future software updates
in addition to the one that the phone's
already received can probably work on
processing the images a bit better
though but as of right now the camera is
just pretty good not the greatest as a
lot of people expected it to be but i
have a full sample image gallery linked
right below that like button if you want
to check all those out now the rest of
sony's experience skin is very familiar
if you've used any other sony phone and
it's obvious that sony is putting a lot
of effort into improving this and making
it a better usage experience it's
running here on top of android 4.2 jelly
bean and since this phone is rocking a
snapdragon 800 processor yes it is a
great performer like it crushes through
benchmarks browses the web super smooth
and very fast and is just all around
rarely stutters at all like you would
expect from a snapdragon 800 device and
as responsive as the software is they've
really added a lot of stuff one example
to take advantage of the larger display
is the smaller windowed apps that we've
seen on other big screen phones they
come from the multitasking menu here and
there's only a few of them but it's a
step in the right direction and
hopefully other apps will be able to
plug into this in the future and there's
also the menu dedicated to power saving
that sony's added in it seems that they
were very concerned with battery life
when they made this phone the xperia z1
has a sealed in 3 000 milliamp hour
battery already so it lasted all day
with regular heavy use but even more
impressive was the standby time it
actually is one of the better standby
times of any android device i've used so
that's thanks to all the modes that
automatically kick in when you're not
using it for a while and the rest of the
using the phone is exactly as you would
expect really i mean i haven't found any
app that it can't handle or any games
that it can't run smoothly it's overall
a buttery experience i'm just hoping
sony keeps their finger on the pulse
here and updates this device to android
4.4 when it comes out because i think
there's going to be some interesting
google experience stuff that skinned
phone users are really going to like so
at the end of the day the xperia z1 is
exactly what it sounds like it's a sort
of a refined tuned up more bold xperia z
which is great because if you really
like the original xperia z you're going
to love the xperia z1 but if you're in
the same boat as me where you didn't
like the xperia z some software wasn't
really for me i didn't like the way it
looked as much
then you're probably not going to like
the xperia z1 either because they're
very similar in that regard but either
way that's why the comments section is
open let us know what you think of the
xperia z1 right down there below and
you'll see me answering a whole bunch of
comments as well below either way thank
you for watching this video if you
enjoyed if you want to see more videos
like this one there's a subscribe button
below as well for you to check that out
click it and never miss another video
thanks for watching and i'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace
[Music]
you